vier junge männer und ein 13 jähriges
mädchen in einem hotelzimmer auf der
reeperbahn im drogenrausch ein 22
jähriger stirbt das war gestern heute
begann der tag in hamburg mit dem
nächsten drogen drama unter jugendlichen
und was sich dahinter verbirgt macht
angst
hubschrauber feuerwehr rettungskräfte
57 donnerstagmorgen während die
hansestadt hamburg erwacht findet ein
spaziergänger drei leblose jugendliche
in einem schrebergarten hinter einer
schule die rettungskräfte sind umgehend
vor ort rücken sogar mit einem
hubschrauber an einen jugendlichen
müssen die rettungskräfte reanimieren es
ist unfassbar
ein 14-jähriges mädchen und zwei 17
jährige jungs mutmaßlich von dem extrem
starken betäubungsmittel oxycontin
vergiftet
ein betäubungsmittel verwandt mit heroin
und doppelt so stark wie monty das
medikament oxycontin bestehend aus purem
oxycodon kommt 1996 auf den markt das
herstellungs- unternehmen perdue bewirbt
das medikament mit der größten marketing
kampagne aller zeiten
das große versprechen zwölf stunden
wirkung keine suchtgefahr also kein
missbrauch ärzte verschreiben das
medikament im minuten-takt empfehlen es
sogar bereits bei leichten kopfschmerzen
zu nehmen doch es ist der drogentod auf
rezept denn die marketing kampagne ist
voller unwahrheiten oxycontin ist
unfassbar süchtig machend und der
urknall für die drogen krise in den
vereinigten staaten
doch wie kommen jugendliche auf die idee
so ein starkes schmerzmittel zu nehmen
die hip-hop-szene glorifiziert die
abhängig machende droge
[Musik]
dieses lied einzig und allein dem
oxycodon gewidmet fast eine million
aufrufe bei youtube und damit in den
köpfen vieler jugendlicher in
deutschland ist die verschreibung von
oxycodon haltigen tabletten streng
reguliert doch auf dem schwarzmarkt sind
sie einfach zu bekommen der unfassbare
vorfall der jugendlichen aus hamburg ist
alarmierend seit seiner reanimation wird
der 17-jährige junge künstlich beatmet
und liegt auf der intensivstation
auch die anderen jugendlichen kommen in
ein krankenhaus
[Musik]
fragen wenn man noch mal nach bei dr
mariska bahn ist er ist ärztlicher
direktor der klinik für suchtmedizin in
stuttgart guten abend herr cannabis
cabana wann sie genau genannt können die
jugendlichen in hamburg haben vermutlich
oxycodon zu sich genommen was ist das
genau wie wirkt das
genau das ist schmerzen bei patienten
die unter starken schmerzen leiden
werden das vielleicht auch schon gehört
haben die eu gibt regelmäßig live video
zur schmerzbehandlung raus und das ist
eben eine eskalationsstufe für schwere
schmerz beschweren ist ein medikament
also was in der medizin auch eingesetzt
wird was gleichzeitig aber ist eine
mannschaft mit dem morphin hohes
abhängigkeitspotenzial hat und
letztendlich aufgrund seiner bewölkung
auch immer wieder von menschen gebraucht
wird die auch substanzen konsumieren um
sich entweder zu euphorisieren oder um
sich müde richtung machen das ist beim
oxycodon in unterschiedlichen
dosierungen möglich nun haben wir
gesehen dass es da eine riesenwelle in
den usa gab die firma der hersteller
musste auch milliarden an schmerzensgeld
ironischerweise in diesem zusammenhang
zahlen warum ist oxycodon so gefährlich
kann es zu so einem massenphänomen
werden
genau das endlich also man muss sagen
das medikament selbst es war gefahren
aber gefährlich ist es wenn es
unkritisch verschrieben wird oder wenn
es eben ohne medizinische begleitung
eingenommen wird du bist medikament hat
ebenso eine wirkung die ist eben schon
erwähnt habe es ist so dass wenn es über
einen längeren zeitraum regelmäßig eine
körperliche abhängigkeit entsteht so
dass wenn man das medikament absetzt er
ist dazu kommt dass man schwitzt unruhe
hat körperliche schmerzen hat bis hin zu
schweren körper phänomen so dass man das
medikament zunächst weiter nehmen muss
oder möchte und die problematik im us
aber eben das ist wie gesagt und
verordnet wurde dann plötzlich
allerdings gestoppt wurde ohne
alternative zu bieten und dann die
menschen im rahmen der zweiten überdosis
krise in den usa ist der zweiten bälle
dann übergegangen sind zum aero
inzwischen in der jetzigen situation in
nordamerika ist das interview was es
sind also ist der bereich der
synthetischen opioide das heißt auch
dass oxycodon ist ein synthetisches
opioide in ihrem bericht ja schon zu
hören das ist ein medikament ist was
stärker ist oder stärker wirksam ist
weil es noch höhere konzentration hat
und gleichzeitig hat es eben effekte die
wenn man es auch eine bestimmte dosis
einstellt euphorisieren zunächst wirken
kann was dann erstmals spaß fördern
empfunden wird oder eben auch gerade bei
menschen die in erklären
lebenssituationen sind oder die schlimme
dinge in der vergangenheit erlebt haben
ein ebenso müde machen können denn
beziehung assoziieren also dass man dann
schlechte gedanken wegdrücken kann dass
man seine emotionen seien stress in
gewisser weise regulieren kann auch eine
nicht funktionale art aber das ist der
effekt die man spürt und deshalb
erfahren dass menschen so dass es am
anfang hilfreich ist also genauso über
den schmerzen auch bei anderen
emotionalen oder
geografischen situation dass es dort
eingesetzt wird und daran auch diesen
medikament hängen bleibt und dann eben
einerseits diesen körperlichen entzug
die gefahr besteht und zum anderen die
andere gefahr ist dass man eben dann
über geht in einen zustand in dem man
nicht mehr so gut erreichbar ist das
jetzt bei dem jungen menschen wo man
auch sagen muss dass für die familie ein
ganz schreckliches erlebnis ist passiert
ist und das ist die große leben wirken
die passieren kann das medikament zu
einer art und depression in der
überdosierung führt das heißt dass die
sauerstoffaufnahme nach unten geht und
denn in der folge man dann irgendwie
entweder in die überwachungs wichtig
wird oder entsprechend auch das risiko
besteht ist man an den folgen einer
überdosierung verstärken kann herr karan
ist das klingt alles sehr dramatisch und
wissen wir dass viele entwicklungen aus
den usa irgendwann auch herüberschwappen
hierher wie können den jugendlichen hier
an diese ja hier
verschreibungspflichtigen medikamente
überhaupt herankommen genau also das ist
in zwei teile sagen also einerseits ist
es mir ein großes anliegen auch nochmal
zu vermitteln dass in deutschland auch
die versorgung von kindern und
jugendlichen jungen erwachsenen mit
substanz konsum insgesamt schon
schwierig ist vor allem auch bei den
opioiden dann muss noch verbesserungen
da sein gleichzeitig ist es aber auch
wichtig dass man eben nicht in panik
gerät jetzt
wenn er sagt das ist eine erkrankung die
auch behandelt werden kann und wo es
auch gute behandlungsansätze liegt wie
bei uns auch im klinikum wichtig ist
eben dass man wird es zutrauen hat in
die behandlung zu gehen gleichzeitig
liegt besorgen sich dass die menschen
und das ist die große frage wie geht man
auch damit um es sind verschiedene
versorgung zu sega inzwischen durch das
beatmet gibt es die möglichkeit sich
rezepte zu ordnen und
mit diesen rezepten dann in die apotheke
zu gehen und dann das dann tatsächlich
von der apotheke direkt zu bekommen das
ist für viele apotheken oft schwierig zu
überprüfen
dann gibt es tatsächlich leider auch
wenige ärzte und ärztinnen dies auch
relativ unkritisch verstanden man sieht
auch dass die verschreibung zahlen und
jugendliche junge erwachsene
doch etwas erhöht ist in den letzten
jahren und das letzte ist dass man es
dann eben wie man andere substanzen auch
im freundeskreis bekommen dann ist es
ein freund eine freundin die an diese
präparate herankommt und den kontakt hat
zur szene oder zu die landes verkaufen
und das dann in ihrem eigenen
freundeskreis verteilen und gemeinsam
einnehmen
besorgniserregende aber wichtige
informationen ganz herzlichen dank dafür
[Musik]